[Musique]
merci Louis carv de nous accompagné
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu de la Haute Savoie membre du
groupe Union centriste vice-président du
Sénat on va bien sûr longuement revenir
avec vous sur ce discours de politique
générale de Gabriel tal d'abord un mot
général qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de
ce discours est-ce que le cap et la
méthode définie hier par le Premier
ministre sont les bons pour vous on va
dire alors que nous nous avons eu ici au
Sénat une lecture par le numéro 2 du
gouvernement Bruno Le Maire que ce qu'on
on peut voir des images à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est quand même une certaine
volonté voir un volontarisme de Gabriel
Atal de faire bouger un certain nombre
de lignes mais le terme général dans le
terme discours de politique générale est
tout à fait approprié c'estàd qu'on n
pas rentré énormément dans le détail et
y compris sur les questions agricole on
est un peu encore sur notre fin parce
que on est dans une période tout à fait
particulière c'est le
début du mandat ou de la de la mission
de de Gabriel Atal et peut-être que nous
en attendons davantage alors alors ça va
sans doute être sur les questions
territoriales être précisé cet
après-midi au Sénat mais globalement on
voit les intentions sans sans percevoir
exactement justement la méthode avec
laquelle il entend mettre en place ces
fameux grands principes de
déburaucratiser de
d le le pays même si on peut même si on
peut le rejoindre dans ses intentions
d'ailleurs le Sénat a porter ce type
d'initiative depuis longtemps ça fait
longtemps qu'on parle de des normes dans
les entreprises ça fait longtemps que
sur l'effet économique du SMIC et le
fait de repousser en permanence le le le
montant du SMIC fait que de plus en plus
de Français sont touchés par ce ce
salaire minimum et que effectivement il
y a une difficulté importante à à à
combatre donc vous la validé cette
expression de desmicardiser la France
mais je comprends tout à fait ce qu'il
veut dire c'estàd que à chaque fois que
vous augmentez le SMIC vous vous vous
rattrapez tous ceux qui sont juste
auudessus du SMIC et infin vous vous
arrivez à avoir un un une un un nombre
de Français très important qui est
autour de du SMIC et ça c'est pas
souhaitable pour un pays comme le nôtre
parce que on vit mal avec le SMIC on
survit avec le SMIC aujourd'hui en
France donc il faut et à forcerie dans
un département comme le mien qui est un
département frontalier il faut vraiment
avoir en tête que on est en train de
fabriquer des pauvres donc je pense que
la prise de conscience sur cet élément
là et est absolument fondamental dans le
moment que nous vivons en particulier
alors valoriser ceux qui travaillent
c'était le message de Gabriel hatal il
s'est beaucoup adressé aux classes
moyenne à la France de l'entre deux
c'est ce qu'il dit là où Emmanuel Macron
avait lui parlé de la France de l'angle
mort mais je crois qu'il a raison je
crois qu'il a raison nous avons en
particulier dans des ménages où les les
deux personnes travaillent dans les
familles monoparentales aujourd'hui
vivre avec un salaire ou vivre avec deux
salaires faibles c'est difficile de de
boucler les fins de mois on le voit dans
le monde agricole qui forceuie puisque
les revenus sont encore encore moins
importants mais je peux vous assurer
qu'aujourd'hui euh quand on parle de
salariés quand on parle d'ouvriers quand
on on parle de petits agriculteurs quand
on parle de d'agents publics il y a il y
a un vrai sujet donc la reconnaissance
du travail c'est quelque chose
d'important je pense par exemple à
l'exemple des instituteurs il va falloir
quand même qu'on pose un certain nombre
de de de questions et je pense que ce
qu'il veut faire veut faire est est
louable en soi après donc augmenter
encore la rémunération des enseignants
des professeurs des Institutes en tout
cas faire en sorte que le travail que
ceux qui se lèvent le matin puissent
vivre de leur travail ça c'est quelque
chose de d'essentiel
il veut donc valoriser ceux qui
travaillent il veut aussi inciter ceux
qui ne travaillent pas à retourner dans
l'emploi il a notamment annoncer la
généralisation des 15 heures d'activité
pour les bénéficiaires du RSA c'est une
bonne chose pour
vous j'ai peur que ce soit une fausse
bonne idée parce que pour
avoir des personnes qui vont faire 15 he
de de d'activité il faut avoir tout un
encadrement et les bénéficiaires du RSA
en France ce sont souvent des gens qui
sont dans dans des difficultés sociales
importantes donc il faut pas être
aussi définitif et bien se dire le le
sur le principe je suis assez d'accord
je pense que c'est c'est bien d'imaginer
et d'encourager les bénéficiaires du RSA
à retourner vers l'emploi maintenant sur
les modalités pratique et de qui
s'occupe de ça il faut pas il faut pas
que ce soit les entreprises ou les
administrations qui récupèrent le
fardeau de cela donc il y a une question
d'accompagnement et de suivi de ces 15
heur de manière concrète donc c'est
là-dessus que moi j'attends de voir
quelles sont les mesures qui sont
apportées par le gouvernement parce que
encore une fois c'était c'est vrai aussi
pour les travaux d'intérêt
général y compris pour les les parents
délinquant j'imagine qu'on va en parler
mais enfin là aussi qui va s'occuper de
ça on pourra faut faut rentrer dans le
concret et c'est là peut-être que le
discours de Gabriel T qui est un
discours d' 1h20 a manqué de de
d'application concrète mais après tout
c'est le travail aussi du Parlement de
de décliner ce genre de chos alors
justement sur le travail du Parlement il
a confirmé la réforme de l'aide médicale
d'État c'était une promesse qu'il avait
faite à la majorité sénatoriale au
moment du vote de la loi immigration
sauf qu'il a dit qu' ser que ça
passerait par voie réglementaire et donc
il n'y aura pas de nouveaux textes
devant le Parlement est-ce que vous
regrettez cette méthode pas du tout je
trouve que c'est plutôt intelligent
d'abord de d'honorer la promesse du
gouvernement faite à la majorité
sénatoriale de ne pas abandonner la
réforme de l'aide médicale d'État il y a
des choses qui ne sont plus acceptables
dans le fonctionnement de l'aide
médicale d'État et il doivent êtreevu et
deuxièmement il a raison de ne pas
ouvrir un nouveau débat parlementaire
sur ce sujet-là la question a été
suffisamment
caricaturale y compris au Sénat mais
aussi dans le débat public à l'Assemblée
nationale que c'est c'est la une
compétence du gouvernement c'est du
réglementaire B pour vos téléspectateurs
de public sat ce matin c'est vraiment la
compétence du gouvernement c'est
l'article 37 de la Constitution ça n'est
pas le domaine de la loi c'est bien à
eux eux gouvernement de faire ce ce
genre de de modifications et j'espère
qu'ils seront courageux parce que on on
a au Sénat fixé un certain nombre de de
d'orientations j'espère que ces
orientations seront respectées notamment
sur la question du panier de soins
auquel les les les étrangers en
situation irrégulière ont droit sur
notre territoire il s'agit bien de les
soigner mais il s'agit pas non plus
d'être excessif il faut retrouver de la
raison sauf que la droite voulait
profiter de cet éventuel débat sur la
réforme de la me pour réintroduire les
mesures de la majorité sénatoriale qui
ont été censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel pour vous il faut les
oublier ces mesures non je crois pas je
mon groupe parlementaire qui est le
groupe de l'Union centriste va déposer
une proposition de loi reprenant un
certain nombre pas toute mais un certain
nombre de ces propositions il y a des
des choses qui étaient qui qui qui
allaient évidemment trop loin qui
étaient inefficace saz quand vous votez
un texte de loi vous vous prenez vous
votez l'ensemble he alors tout tout ne
vous plaît pas nous les centristes on va
déposer ce qui ce qui nous convient et
on on ins rapidement très rapidement
dans les jours qui viennent et on
inscrira sans doute dans dans l'une de
nos niches parlementaires c'est un
moment où on aura la la possibilité de
débattre de cela quelle mesure il faut
oublier pour vous mais par exemple la
question des cautions sur les étudiants
franchement enfin faut être
sérieux parfois l'espèce de concours
l'épine en matière d'immigration espèce
de concours l'épine et
et va à l'encontre même de ce que nous
sommes nous-mêmes c'est-à-dire un pays
ouvert sur le monde qui accueille des
étudiants étrangers voilà je preneis
vous me posez la question je vous donne
un exemple très concret je trouve que
c'était pas pas intelligent de de jeter
le PROE sur les étudiants étrangers dont
nous avons besoin et qui font l'honneur
de l'université française gabrielal a
également consacré une partie de son
discours aux questions de sécurité et de
lutte contre le trafic de drogue il a
réitéré la mesure annoncée par Emmanuel
Macron 10 opérations place net par
semaine il a fait une nouvelle annonce
pour s'attaquer au trafiant de drogue on
l'écoute nous allons encore monter d'un
cran dans notre combat contre la drogue
en mettant en uvre un nouveau plan de
lutte contre les stupéfiant notre
stratégie de harcèlement et de pilonnage
contre les dealers porte ses fruits nous
avons réussi à faire disparaître un/art
des points de Deal alors nous allons
poursuivre avec 10 opérations place net
par semaine nous devons aussi taper les
dealurs au porte-monnaie et leur couper
les vivre c'est pourquoi nous allons
désormais geler les avoirs des
trafiquants de drogue qui sont
identifiés gel des avoirs pour les
trafiant en drogue identifié c'est la
nouvelle mesure est-ce que c'est une
bonne mesure est-ce que c'est réaliste
est-ce que c'est opérationnel il faut
par tous les moyens combattre trafic de
drogue dans notre pays alors le premier
ministre il est de 89 moi je suis de 80
et euh quand on quand quand j'étais euh
je adolescent je peux vous assurer qu'
il y avait une vraie conscience de de la
drogue des dégâts de la toxicomanie dans
notre pays et aujourd'hui on a vu se
développer dans tout un tas de quartiers
une économie une économie grise des
quartiers entiers qui vivent de de de
ces trafics et qui pourrissent la vie
des habitants ou de ces quartiers ou des
quartiers périphériques donc la la je ne
peut être que favorable à des mesures
extrêmement sévères ça fait beaucoup de
victimes dans notre pays la drogue et
ces trafics doivent être combattu avec
énormément de de volonté et donc tout ce
qui pourrait être fait y compris les
geles des avoir même si même si ce sera
évidemment très compliqué mais il faut
le faire quand même il a dit Gabriel
hatal que le gouvernement réussi à faire
disparaître un/art des points de Deal
vous saluez la politique du gouvernement
sur cette lutte contre le trafic tout ce
qui pourra être fait doit être doit
avoir le soutien de la représentation
nationale et en particulier du
Sénat personne ne doit manquer à l'appel
de la lutte contre le les trafic de
drogue il s'est également exprimé sur la
lutte contre la délinquence on va
réécouter un autre extrait de son
discours gabrielel qui a voulu se
montrer très ferme avec les délinquant
et notamment avec les Mina on ne négocie
pas avec la République on l'accepte on
la respecte en entier sans mai sans la
moindre
exception nous devons disposer de
sanctions adaptées pour les mineurs de
moins de 16 ans pour eux on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui prononcer de peines de
travaux d'intérêt général je vous
annonce que nous créerons des travaux
d'intérêt éducatif qui seront leur
équivalents et seront donnés plus
facilement que des peines d'intérêt
général cela fera partie de la révision
de l'échelle des sanctions dans nos
établissements scolaires que j'évoquéis
il y a un instant dès le plus jeune âge
il faut en revenir à un principe clair
tu casses tu répares tu ses tu nettoies
tu défies l'autorité on t'apprend à la
respecter là aussi message de fermeté de
Gabriel àal à l'encontre des des
délinquants C là aussi c'est le bon
message qu'il a envoyé hier il fallait
prononcer ces mots
vous mettez-vous à la place des Français
qui dans un certain nombre de d'endroits
du pays vivent la délinquence du
cotidien et ce qu'on a appelé à tort
d'ailleurs les incivilités qui en fait
sont des des des des des délits ou des
contraventions
importantes ça pourrit la vie des
Français et la question de
l'autorité dans la famille à l'école
dans la société plus généralement c'est
une question qu'on ne peut pas traiter
d'un d'un h demain en disant ça n'existe
pas et cetera puis il a leurance de 45
pour pour protéger les mineurs il faut
prendre les choses telles qu'elles sont
après encore une fois là il a donné une
mesure qui est la question de ses
travaux d'intérêt éducatif on a à faire
on a on a affaire à des mineurs de moins
de 16 ans euh moi je suis pas fermé à ce
type de de de mesure j'étais rapporteur
ici au Sénat de l'ensemble des texte sur
des questions de sécurité de ces
dernières années donc je suis pas fermé
à ça encore une fois ça va être une
question aussi d'accompagnement parce
que qui va s'occuper de faire ses
travaux d'intérêt éducatif à force ris
si en plus on condamne les parents à
faire des travaux d'intérêt général qui
va s'occuper de cela et vous savez le
Premier ministre dans dans son discours
il a parlé des parents d'enfants
délinquants et tout de suite derrière il
a parlé des m célibataire en disant
qu'elles ont beaucoup de difficultés
donc c espèce de en même temps en
essayant d'être ferme mais en trouvant
aussi des excuses en trouvant des pas
des excuse des circonstances sociales
montrent la grande très grande
difficulté on on aura faire à des
publics qui qui qui ont des difficultés
d'ordre social et il faudra avoir des
travailleurs sociaux qui ont les
compétences pour faire ce travail
d'accompagnement donc c'est tout ça se
rattache aussi à la à une grande
question qu'il faut qu'on repose et je
je je je je me réfère au aux travaux de
Jean-Louis borlot sur la question de la
politique de la ville parce que vous
avez des mesures individuelles sur un
mineur délinquant sur sa famille mais de
manière plus générale il y a la question
aussi des quartiers dans lesquels ces
ces familles vivent et où on doit avoir
une politique structurelle alors pour
couper les jeunes de leur mauvaise
fréquentation c'est ce qu'a dit hier
Gabriel Atal quand un jeune est sur la
mauvaise pente c'est ce qu'il a dit il
propose de les placer dans un internat
en les aidant en aidant les familles sur
le plan financier est-ce que c'est la
bonne voie ah moi je crois beaucoup au
vertuus de l'internat euh je le dis en
tant que pè de famille ilant deux
enfants qui sont par choix à l'internat
je crois que euh c'est une des manières
on va va dire à partir de la 6e qui peut
permettre à un certain nombre d'enfants
d'adolescents de
retrouver une une structure mentale qui
leur permet d'affronter leurs études et
ensuite d'avoir
d'acquérir ce que parfois les familles
ne leurontt pas transmis c'est-à-dire un
certain nombre de de relations à la vie
en société euh donc je trouve que ce
sont des des des bonnes idées l'internat
c'est pas la prison l'internat c'est
pas voilà les le comment c'est pas
Merlus de Marcel pagol c'est c'est aussi
des endroits de vie de vie en
collectivité et où on apprend ou parfois
même on réapprend les règles de vie en
société moi je trouve que c'est une idée
qui est tout à fait intéressante y
compris pour des familles qui ont des
difficultés à à faire face à à des
enfants qui seront plutôt des trubilons
qui ont du mal à avec l'autorité
parentale et l'autorité qu'on doit avoir
dans une dans la vie en société
gabrielal était évidemment attendu sur
la question agricole quelle réponse
apporter aux agricul ulteur en colère ça
a fait l'actualité dans votre
département on va y aller tout de suite
on va NC on retrouve Sébastien Germain
bonjour Sébastien merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous pour rédacteur en chef à H
Montblanc c'est la télévision locale en
haut de Savoie on fait le point avec
vous d'abord sur les blocages dans votre
région est-ce que le mouvement
s'essouffle alors on peut dire qu'il
s'est souff un petit puisque le péage la
barrière de de péage le blocage de la
barrière de péage de été levé ce mardi
mais levé par la FDSEA mais celui qui
est constitué au au niveau de la
barrière de péage d'allonsacaille au
nord de l'agglomération anéienne est
toujours en cours un maintien du vote un
maintien du blocage a été voté à main à
main levée
notamment Sébastien vous avez des
questions pour le ikv
oui le ik alors je disais n'ont paschapp
bonjour déjà les pays de Sava n'ont pas
échappé au mouvement de contestation et
de mobilisation du monde agricole vous
avez affiché vous votre soutien aux
agriculteurs avec le hashtag soutien aux
agriculteurs dans quelle mesure vous
compenez cette
dans quelle mesure je compr dans quelle
mesure Sébastien on a des des petits
problèmes de son est-ce que vous pouvez
répéter la question parce que ça ça a
coupé pour dire je
dis dans quelle mesure vous comprenez la
colère du monde paysan lis carv ah bah
vous savez Sébastien c'est un un monde
que je connais bien ha savoi les élus et
moi en particulier on est très proche du
monde du monde agricole et c'est pour ça
que dans la journée de lundi j'ai voulu
aller à le rencontre sur les deux
blocages dont vous avez parlé à l la
caille et à
Cluse la réalité du mon e agricole
français est une réalité complexe parce
que d'un betterravier de la Meuse à un
éleveur de canard dans le Gers ou à des
producteur de
roblechon en haut de sa voie vous avez
forcément des des choses qui sont
différentes mais ce que ce que ce que
j'entends de de de ce qu'ils ont pu nous
dire un les normes
euh les étouffes le travail
administratif d'un agriculteur est
beaucoup trop important par rapport à la
au chiffre d'affaires d'une d'une telle
entreprise agricole de le travail ne ne
rémunère plus assez et ça c'est très
inquiétant en soi de voir qu'en fait ben
alors que il travaille souvent 7 jours
sur 7 365 jours par an le la
rémunération est est pas assez
importante et puis chez nous en haut de
sa voie on a deux questions qui sont qui
remontent qui est la question de la
prédation et la question du loup le la
population lupine explose dans les Alpes
françaises et donc on a une
préoccupation autour de la question du
loup et toujours cette question de
bruxellose dans le massif des aravies
qui est une maladie du bouquetin
potentiellement transmissible au bovin
voire à l'être humain et sur lequel on a
on a toujours une difficulté à être
certain qu'on a qu'on a cette affaire de
la bruxellose derrière nous donc en fait
tout remonte et j'ai pu aller voir donc
les deux les deux
organisations que sont la Fédération la
FDSEA et les jeunes agriculteurs d'une
part et puis la Coordination Rurale par
ailleurs et donc engager un un dialogue
entre entre eux et nous sur la question
la première question qui est la question
des normes il y a un travail qui doit
être engagé par les préfets et donc moi
je Seris très vigilant à ce qu'en vous
de savoir on est ce travail qui soit
fait pour que les arrêtés préfectoraux
soient les
plus circonstanciés et les moins lourds
en application pour nos amis pour nos
amis paysans de la Haute Savoie Gabriel
Atal était évidemment très attendu hier
sur ses réponses à apportter aux
agriculteur finalement on n' pas eu
beaucoup d'annonces on a plus su le
détail de de de mesures déjà annoncé
est-ce qu'il vous a déçu sur ce point ah
c'est une très grande surprise parce que
on s'attendait à avoir une part
significative du discours de politique
générale consacré euh à l'agriculture ça
a été évoqué effleuré et depuis vendredi
avec les annonces qui ont été faites
dans le département euh de HauteGaronne
et et aujourd'hui on trouve enfin je
trouve qu'il y a assez peu d'évolution
donc on attend encore des mesures plus
plus concrètes elles sont annoncées par
le gouvernement est-ce que ce sera
aujourd'hui on verra bien mais en tout
cas il y a il y a nécessité de de
clarifier et de préciser les mesures euh
sur quel point notamment vous qui avez
rencontré les agricultteur sur quel
point il est urgent d'agir il faut de
nouvelles mesures en plus des annonces
de vendredi ah moi je pense qu'il faut
des mesures qui soient des mesures en
direction de la rémunération et et donc
il faut que le le travail paye donc
au-delà des contrôles d'galim mais bien
sûr ça ben euh il faut s'assurer que
égalim l'application des galimes se
traduit concrètement par l'amélioration
du revenu des agriculteurs par par
rapport à la production quand vous
comparez le prix d'un litre de
lait acheté dans dans dans
l'exploitation et sa commercialisation
vous voyez bien qu'il y a un problème
donc il faut qu'on il faut qu' qu'il y
ait une amélioration significative des
choses et puis sur les questions
notamment de l'eau on peut pas se
limiter à dire il on va réduire les
délais de recours on va on va supprimer
un niveau de juridiction en cas de en
cas de recours il faut concrètement une
politique claire sur l'eau et
l'agriculture en France vous savez mais
parle d'un fond hydraulique est-ce que
ça c'est
suffisant non il faut une philosophie
avir un fond mais non mais il faut une
philosophie avoir un fond regardez il y
a 10 ans sur la question nucléaire on
s'est dit on va arrêter le nucléaire en
France aujourd'hui on construit des
centrales nucléaires donc il
faut faire un virage à 180°r il faut
changer notre relation à l'agriculture
et comprendre que dans ce pays qui est
une grande nation
agricole on on a on on est on a parmi
les meilleures productions du monde on
est reconnu dans le monde entier on doit
euh quand quand le Premier ministre dit
je place l'agriculture au-dessus de tout
moi je comprends ce qu'il veut dire ça
veut dire qu'en fait on doit remettre
l'agriculture au bon niveau et au bon
endroit et donc avoir une foi dans le
monde agricole c'est leur donner une
capacité de vivre de leur travail et et
et d'avoir un certain nombre de de
politiques publiqu qui se mettent en
ligne là-dessus donc la question de
l'eau elle est elle est fondamentale
nous devons par exemple en France être
capable de retenir davantage d'eau
notamment l'hiver pour la la pouvoir
l'utiliser l'été dans le nord de clair
pardon ça veut dire il faut faciliter la
construction de bassine il faut
faciliter la construction de retenu
d'eau les bassines c'est sont C ces
énormes qui qui ont fait l'objet de de
de polémique de manifestation et ceetera
mais en tout cas il faut imaginer qu'on
soit en capacité de garder de l'eau qui
sera restitué au milieu naturel à une
période différée dans le nord de
l'Europe en adaptation au changement
climatique ils ont construit 30 ou 40 %
de bassine de plus en 10 an il faut
qu'on ait un plan en France d'adaptation
au changement climatique qui permet de
de stocker de l'eau quand il y en a pour
le restituer plus tard dans la saison
c'est quand même pas dramatique de
d'aller là-dessus je vois même pas
pourquoi le monde environnemental
pourrait être contre une une évidence
pareil on voit que les agriculteurs
continuent de de converger vers Paris
continuent de bloquer dans d'autres
endroits du pays ils ont raison pour
vous de continuer ce mode d'action
écoutez euh globalement c'est une
mobilisation qui se passe bien qui a le
soutien des Français euh les
parlementaires les représentants élus
vont au contact des agriculteurs dans la
mesure où les choses se passent dans la
Concorde et dans la et dans la paix il y
a évidemment aucune difficulté à ce
qu'il puisse continuer leur leur le leur
mouvement euh la question maintenant
c'est c'est de savoir à quel moment les
réponses seront suffisamment à la
hauteur pour qu'on ait une réponse qui
leur soit apportée et attention au
risque de contagion parce que moi j'ai
rencontré les taxis j'ai rencontré les
le le monde du des travaux publics vous
savez que le promotion immobilière va
très mal dans notre pays et donc on a
aussi un risque d'avoir une extension de
de ce conflit à d'autres secteurs de
l'économie qui ont aussi des choses à
dire et qui sont légitimes à le faire on
remercie Sébastien Germain merci
beaucoup merci Sébastien d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous parler de cette
situation agricole en Haute Savoie merci
et et à très vite un mot sur une autre
phrase de Gabriel hatade il a dit hier
en fin de discours nous inscrirons l'IVG
dans la Constitution est-ce qu'après le
vote de l'Assemblée nationale qui a été
large hier il peut compter sur celui du
Sénat ah je suis pas certain en tout cas
dans la rédaction actuelle qui est
prévue qui a été voté à l'Assemblée
nationale il y aura un débat ici
important d'abord sur la question même
de savoir si c'est opportun de mettre ce
cette rédaction dans la Constitution
c'est opportun vous moi je voterai
contre et et je suis totalement
solidaire de ce que le président Larché
a dit Simon veille elle-même était
contre le fait de mettre une une
inscription constitutionnelle sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et d'ailleurs si vous regardez les
chos inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution
c'est donner le pouvoir au juges
constitutionnel c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé aux États-Unis en 73 vous
avez une décision qui fait du droit à
l'IVG un droit fédéral et et vous avez
48 ans plus tard un retour en arrière la
question des modalités dans
lesquelles on a accès à l'interruption
venteur de grossesse ça doit rester la
compétence du Parlement et pas la
compétence des juges constitutionnels
donc c'est une fausse bonne idée de
penser qu'on va protéger l'IVG en la
mettant dans la Constitution au
contraire je pense que ça peut se
retourner contre les les propres auteurs
après évidemment si on veut en faire un
message politique au monde et utiliser
la Constitution pour ça on se on se
trompe alors je sais que c'est très
compliqué d'intervenir sur un sujet
comme celui-là puisque quand vous dites
que vous êtes contre l'inscription du
livg dans la Constitution on va
automatiquement dire que vous êtes
contre l'IVG tout court ce qui n'est pas
le cas mais il faut être précis et et et
être et le Sénat a un rôle de protection
du texte fondamental c'est on peut pas
on peut pas mettre tout et n'importe
quoi dans la Constitution je ne dis pas
que l'IVG c'est tout et n'importe quoi
mais quand on le fait il faut être il
faut être bien conscient des
conséquences que ça peut avoir demain
est-ce qu'on connaît la composition du
conseil constitutionnel est-ce que le
Conseil constitionnel sera plus
conservateur plus libéral qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui moi je ne le sais pas donc
faut faire preuve de beaucoup d'humilité
et se dire que les conséquences on les
aura dans 10 ans aujourd'hui la question
de l'IVG en France c'est la question de
l'accès il y a 17 départements dans
lesquels il n'y a pas de de cent IVG et
pour lesquels en dans le monde rural les
femmes qui souhaitent avoir recours à
univg ont ont besoin d'aller à des
centaines de kilomètres de chez elle et
ça c'est pas l'inscription de la
Constitution qui va changer la moindre
réalité de ce qu'elles vivent le mot
décentralisation n'a pas été prononcé
hier par Gabriel hatal il réserve ses
annonces pour les territoires au Sénat
cet après-midi qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de son discours sur le sujet le
pays crève de sa centralisation le pays
crève de réforme inabouti ou
Infiné l'État est puissant là où il est
atillon là où il n'a plus besoin de
l'être puisque ce sont des compétences
qui sont transféré aux collectivités
territoriales et il est impuissant et
faible sur le régalien donc en fait la
réforme de la politique territoriale de
dans le pays c'est encreux une réforme
de l'État et moi ce que j'attends du du
du du Premier ministre cet après-midi
devant le Sénat il ça va être une
déclaration d'amour he les maires sont
formidables et devant les sénateurs il
ne peut faire qu'un tabac en disant ça
et tous les premiers ministres l' l'ont
fait par contre on attend nous une
clarification et sur un certain nombre
de dossiers importants que va-til il
déciderer sur l' l'assaainissement par
exemple que les sénateurs sont très
mobilisés sur cette question là que
vaut-t-il décider sur le zan le zéro
artificialisation net où est-ce qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on va avancer et et
comment est-ce qu'on va être capable de
d'avoir un pays enfin dans lequel l'État
garde ses compétences principales et et
fait confiance aux élus et leur donne
les moyens d'agir et leur donne les
moyens d'agir pour que on puisse avoir
un un un vrai un vrai
jardin un vrai jardin qui devrait être
notre pays c'estàd dans lequel voilà les
territoires s'adaptent Innov de manière
intelligente et non pas soit dans une
espèce de logique jacobine qui n'a plus
lie d'ê un dernier mot le on attend la
suite de la composition du
gouvernemental est-ce que pour vous il
faut qu'il y ait des UD est-ce que vous
avez envie d'entrer dans ce gouvernement
vous alors moi je suis pas membre de
l'UDI je suis membre du Nouveau Centre
parti d'HV Morin
centr je me pose pas la question C terme
là pour mais on vous le propose c'est
pas non à moi euh je je je me pose pas
une question qui ne se pose pas
aujourd'hui je j'ai j'ai absolument pas
ni l'envie ni l'envie ni coup de
téléphone pour rentrer au gouvernement
il y a pas de scoop pour les les
téléspectateurs en tout cas il y a la
volonté aujourd'hui d'élargir la
majorité présidentielle est un leur à
part Rachida Dati et Madame
vaurin qui sont des personnalités des
républicains qui rent mantine V oui mais
qui rentre au gouvernement sans faire
rentrer des formations politiques et des
parlementaires avec eux ce sont des des
des débauchages individuels donc si
c'était mon cas en terme de débauchage
individuel ce serait non voilà le
message est clair merci lu Hervé merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité pour
parler de ce discours de politique
générale de gabrielleal